[Music]
all right well look man uh blue lakehead
podcast
uh real ninety two honored to have
all of the members of goody mob on the
podcast now i got to give you all some
context on what first you know i'm 33.
so the first record i ever heard of
y'alls
that made me just dive in
was obviously still standing what was
that night was that 98
97 no you worried about nice
my best friend ramses played me they
don't dance no mo
and ceelo your last verse on that record
my name is
listen man i heard your voice your voice
and your flow is so it blew my whole
[ __ ] head off as a kid bro
and um and i you know from there i had
to go back and tap in with the first
album but
that was my first taste of of getting
introduced to you guys so 98
97 i was like 10 or 11 years old
so man i've been a fan for a very long
time and uh
that's dope man yeah it's dope to see
all y'all back together man uh
you know and especially uh with the
right production
with organized noise
you know what i'm saying like um this is
what i know you guys have been hearing
all the fans harping at you for so long
to do this specific project including my
back together
with organized noise why was the timing
right in 2020
because of that fact right there it was
it was resounding overwhelming
you know uh insistent consistent and
people always
say they want the old thing back man
we've been take us back to the beginning
you know what i mean take us back to
where it all started
and then sometimes you know you know in
your travels you know you get so far
away from home man like you know
um you know you you forget to look back
then say you feel me
sometimes people people forget how to go
back i mean like
other times people aren't even welcome
to come back
with none of us you know i mean like you
know um
fortunately man like you know home is
always what a heart is man like you know
and you know um to come back to organize
lawyers to have
the original you know first generation
dungeon family
the ones who you know who who who built
the pillars man they built and built the
foundation man like
it's uh it's incomparable and i'm saying
like it didn't also
have big and drain me like that's the
original well this it was
that's the original nine the magnificent
nine man you know right there
what i mean so it's crazy man what can i
say man we proud
and excited for people to hear what
we've got how long was
uh the crew were how long like i guess
when did the conception of this album
start how long have you guys
been working on this project and i know
all of you guys are aware of how
important this is to
dungeon family fans outcast fans goody
mob fans fans are real hip hop
so i'm sure you guys took your time when
did y'all start first working on this
project
to be for real with you we did this
project in the last five months
okay so this was uh under quarantine
yeah this was under quantity
oh [ __ ] okay everybody everything on
this album is brand new
i mean i guess that makes sense you know
a lot of the content that i heard and
then obviously the name of the album
that would that make sense
yeah so that doesn't let you know we
once this quarantine hit
we made a decision that we was going to
come together we got we got in a secret
location on the south side of atlanta
and once the beast started flowing the
first record we recorded it was
survival kit and then one survival kit
to the amulet the avalanche came
it was just like we just kept going we
kept going so here it is again man
november 13th 2020 new album survival
kid
this is a long time coming it's a
it's a long time coming um like you said
uh ceelo
the original nine on the project um
you know we've we've noticed how uh hard
it is to get
andre versus fans over over
x amount of years you know we sometimes
will get one a year and just be super
excited it might
pop up on a gz album or a remix or
something um
it's only right that he's on the new
goodie mob album but how how how uh how
the andre verse come to be and like
was it was it difficult i know it's not
difficult because y'all are family but
like
you know that's an important verse to
have on a goody mob album with organized
noise behind the production
man we won't even speak about the
difficulties or whatnot you mean like
you know we'll just only
speak about the end result you mean like
you know and uh
the end result is the camaraderie the
connection
you know um the respect the dignity the
love and i mean like
you know the blood i mean like you know
that we it's a it's a family thing i
mean like
and you know we we embrace each other's
indifferences man that's
that's part of what made us very special
man like you know everybody is unique
in their own right it resembles the
right let me like to be that to me like
and and voice that they may like and so
like jordan is one of those highly
integrable
people he's an artist artist you know
what i mean right yeah and i also like
to consider myself as such but like
since we speaking of him i mean like you
know
we've grown we've grown to just embrace
the fact that man like
something that he's truly not into you
know i mean like
you know he ain't into it and i've seen
dog like
just just like you know just for fun i
just tell you man we've seen
what turned out multi millions of
dollars everybody know that
ain't never said like we could all smile
and laugh at that because it's like yo
like you know and that that way the ball
was set
so anything that he decides that's that
he don't necessarily want to do him got
no passion for it
you know me like nobody could even
really argue with that because we're
gonna see him turn down
all kind of [ __ ] no i was so excited you
know
it was crazy because as a fan i was
afraid that i was going to die without
ever seeing outcasts perform
in my life and then a few years ago they
did that festival run
and i got to see them in tampa and i was
like all right that's off the bucket
list you know
but i feel like there's been so much
energy that's led up to your guys's
moment here i want to also shout out
i feel like cass coming together for
that festival run
and then the importance of the
documentary that came out about
organized noise
i think that also brought a lot of
awareness to
just that whole wave of of of what you
guys brought to the game and then now
we're here
and we have a new album survival kit um
i want to go back to the early dungeon
family days there's a couple
of people who who a lot of people don't
know or associate with dungeon family
and i want to kind of get your guys some
some context and some takes on on being
around because i heard
usher was a part of the dungeon family
or at least around y'all super early
um and the same thing with future
obviously future's got a tattooed on his
arm
um but but can you guys kind of talk
about like like being around there like
i sure obviously was a kid
um from what i i think i talked to big
boy about it but
you know just the important historical
context of
let's come from your guys's tree we
could throw usher in that we could throw
future in that what was it like being
around those guys before we all
obviously you know knew who they were
hey look at that it was family man you
know what i'm saying there wasn't really
nothing exciting about being around none
of who was excited because we loved each
other you know what i'm saying nobody
had really accomplished nothing great at
that particular time
so you know what i'm saying the magic
was just just being around people that
you love people
that support you and people that you
support you know what i'm saying
and they were younger than us so they're
like little brothers they used to watch
us
you know what i'm saying they used to
come to the studio i can remember seeing
you know we just called future me
here back in the day me head i can
remember the first time he came to the
studio
you know rico was like yeah that's my
little cousin you know what i'm saying i
met he was real cool real
real quiet guy you know saw spoken word
with it
loud he liked to learn he had to sit
around and really peep out everything
everything was working and i can
remember popping in back in the day like
dungeon was was always just open door
policy for all of us
so i mean you can go over to the dungeon
man at three in the morning
you know 4 30 in the morning you know
what i'm saying somebody going to be up
you know and it's going to be somebody
we
talked to kick it for a few minutes if
you want to go oh you can do that you
want to stay you can stay
you know what i'm saying i can remember
coming in and seeing future just working
in the studio just right i'm like who is
that
like man that's me here damn you know he
about working you know he
put it in you know i could really just
see his energy his
his passion yeah and
it showed and it's still showing you
know i'm saying he wonder he won the
best in the game right now
you know what i'm saying period hands
down can't nobody argue with that
you know what i mean and um it's lovely
to know
you know we saw him grow and the good
thing about it when we tell
his day is still the love and respect
though you know what i'm saying because
you know he's a real gentleman he really
you know real doctor family member
you know what i'm saying that's how we
roll but yeah man um usher i don't
remember seeing him rhino but i do
remember seeing
he wrote something on that uh hot water
heater he wrote questions and i was
trying to figure out
what who was also what was that you know
i never knew what that meant then i
remember meeting him he was a little kid
no he was a kid yeah from what i heard
yeah
yeah he was a little he was a child just
like uh oh yeah who else came out from
under that you didn't know about you
ain't saying about that's uh
mr bobby valentino okay yeah they used
to come over there all the time remember
they were little kids
you know man coming over there you know
what i'm saying sucking up gang
you know what i'm saying getting tracks
you know saying learning learning the
ropes learning how to move
you know i mean and bobby held on to it
you know
i was closer to him because i knew me
and cujo and gil
uh graduated from high school with his
sister his older sister
so that's family that's little marcel to
the end you know what i mean so
you know we all family we all brothers
we all love each other we all support
each other man that's just how it is
right here around the dungeon family man
hey it's a beautiful thing to see it man
it's a beautiful thing what was um
for you guys like when
obviously you say you got andy you
decide all right we got to make an album
um having organized noise
handle the production was that like i'm
assuming there was just
a mutual understanding that like if
we're going to do this there's only one
way we do it and that's to have them
be behind the boards is that
is that was it was that that was had to
be the easiest decision i'm assuming
with this project
yeah entertaining yeah go ahead joe
i mean then you could say something too
it felt good not to have a big
[ __ ] for beats a big
[ __ ] for tracks you know what
i'm saying i have to worry about
man how much i charge for a trash [ __ ]
just a hundred thousand oh damn for real
all right i'm sorry so it felt good man
to just go back in the ring
man with somebody we were familiar with
man go ahead girl
uh familiar with is all the way i think
that that
that brought the comfort down for
everybody i it really gave
everybody in this group a real chance to
sit back and say okay
what am i going to do what am i going to
bring to this project at the same time
they were doing the same thing amongst
them you know sleepy
reek and ray you know what i mean like
and like even during the air i'm like
on sometimes bro we got up to nine mixes
on just one record you know what i mean
so that's how
that's how diligent they was going
that's how that they was working on a
night and day
you know i mean so we get this beautiful
project at the end
it's like man i can't we can't wait till
friday the 13th so people can hit the
survival kit
because we know it's going to be just
like the rest of it's going to be a
classic
we're going to find out 25 years from
now
yeah you guys have have classic in your
i mean listen man i
i listen to soul food still like it just
came out
often you know you know it's it's it's a
timeless body of work still standing
times body work
i'm curious ceelo i know that your solo
success has been
and shout out to gib too by the way get
uh the [ __ ] you dropped to do for the
lunatics was my [ __ ]
ali right careful ali yeah
yep yep but ceelo i want to touch i i
know
your solo success your [ __ ] would uh
obviously your solo your first solo
project was crazy then
barkley came up it was crazy and you're
a superstar
in your own right um how how like
is it dope to be able to introduce fans
of yours that might not be goody mob
fans
to goody mob 25 years later because
there are fans of yours
that might not they might be just
surface level cello fans then i might
not like
dig into the fact that you came from
goody mob how dope is that to bring a
bunch of new
fans to the party because my mom is a
ceelo fan she don't know what the [ __ ]
goody mob is but she knows who you are
you know what i'm saying right
right you know i don't mind surface
level ceelo green fans
but i do my superficial silo green fans
you know me
and there's a difference let me like the
ones that are truly
um aware of me they're aware of the root
of you know me like
and the origin of what away come from
you know me like you know
why you know why not why not follow me
back
why not trace me back to the beginning
you know what i'm saying like you feel
me
um so you know i
it's not it's not a conflict of interest
not not not to me i'm saying like or
anyone for that matter
you know what i'm saying like you know
like it's only
um weight to leverage with you know what
i'm saying like you know and weight
weight distribution you know what i'm
saying so right right right you know
um i believe that
personally i believe that you know any
any wind you know on this side of it i
mean that is a win for everyone
so you know i believe that gnarls
broccoli sea little green i mean like
and any success associated with it you
know
extends itself from dungeon family so
it's essentially and ultimately
a dungeon family win no different than
without cass it like
when speaker box love below vote to
win grammy album of the year
you know what i'm saying and um and
that that's it that's me trying to
really keep that simple
you know what i mean but like um but no
man it's
it's all relative and this derivative of
where something starts from a starting
point
you know what i'm saying so um you know
the having the the support system
having um the success ratio the me like
and the strength of the mob and of the
dungeon family
you know behind me themselves is what
propelled me
to those heights you know i'm saying
like you know even if it was used as
a barometer of something i wanted to do
better or do more
of you know what i'm saying um but all
in an effort to
represent you know not only my family
who said like you know
but our city let me like to the best of
my natural ability
let and so what you hear
is just the humility that that come
along with that i mean like so like
i wasn't i ain't never really tripping
and saying you feel me like because my
feet my feet in the dirt man you know i
come out the dirt you mean
i'm just like i ain't gonna trip off
starter man like
you know i'm a tall tree i'm saying like
or a tall and an even taller antenna
so i'm up there i can pick up that i
pick up a signal you know what i'm
saying like
and i get the message and i transmit and
i transcend
and that's it hey hey when i was uh
coming up man
i i remember as because i'm a die hard
outcast fan
die hard dungeon family fan when you
guys all came together
for uh even in darkness right i thought
that was
i mean i'm even like i remember cool or
cool breezes
east boy's finest album that watch for
the hook was my [ __ ] i'm a huge dungeon
family fan so when everybody got
together and made even in darkness
it was crazy can you guys give me some
uh like a story or two
about the making of the actual dungeon
family album because
i think that that album is very slept on
and doesn't get enough
i don't hear enough conversation or
praise about how dope that project was
that's a good example man use a cool
breeze esports greatest hit
i mean that song watch for the hook man
like you know that's when you know his
project was launched off the back of
organized noise you know um you know
uh opening up the doors you know cutting
the ribbon on
their new label overnight records you
know me like you know um
uh organized noise uh via
interscope you know what i'm saying so
that was that was a big look and i mean
so we all came together
you know like with the camaraderie with
the teamwork to make that dream work man
like for the homie you know what i mean
no different than he showed up for us
when he called the phrase dirty south
let me like
and lend it that i'm saying you feel me
to uh to to good mob's debut album so
like you mean like
you know the love is reciprocated you
know what i mean right you feel me i
always acknowledge it
where it's dude i'm saying so you know
like you want no egos and then another
that kind of [ __ ] let me like
the whole it was a homie turn we we we
you know
we chained up you know he got suited up
and got on the field with him and that's
what it was about
yeah but with the even darkness album
what was that
like that's that's a hard thing to pull
everybody together especially at that
point of everyone's careers
because you guys are all at that point
in time cast is [ __ ] out of here
and then you got freaking out of here
and to bring everyone together
what what what what i'm assuming that uh
was it organized noise that kind of
quarterbacked the creative process for
that project like
or what was it what was making that
album like
it was organized noise because i'm we
was both on tour
like outcast was doing smoking grooves
too i think goody mom was out with uh
i think we just came off uh fishbone and
daylight soul tour
oh [ __ ] so so it was it was it was a
real
crazy time so we was doing the records
in and out coming in and out of time
you know like so we didn't really get to
start
to even do that through that album we
didn't get the tour
a lot because just our schedules man it
was just we was just doing so much at
that time
i can imagine um with this project
what uh what what was the
with the word survival kit i mean like
when i see that and
go ahead you know what labels don't
support big albums like that bro and why
that stuff only happened every so often
not because they don't want to see
something great you don't mean like you
know but
because logistically projects like that
are expensive to do
you know i'm saying it's a lot of work
in parts
especially if everyone's on different
labels different labels and different
tax brackets and pay grades contain
all of that yeah it takes a lot of
humility from everyone involved right
yeah yeah because like you said
there might be somebody who'd be like yo
man i'll do it but i need more than this
person and it's like nah
we're not doing it for that we're doing
it because it ain't even anything about
having more than that
it's about i need what i deserve right
yeah because y'all gonna turn right back
around and promote this to my audience
inside the orders that i've earned and
work for
so you people send it back to them
you're gonna say like you know
at least give me yeah damn you know
right right right right
what i need is a little [ __ ]
hey i'm curious um was there ever a
record
or any sort of moment creatively that
you guys as a group regret
looking back on on your guys's career
you know even though now we come back
together
and we talk about that we laugh about it
now but like
i gotta say another age against machine
album you know there's some regretful
parts on there
for me man cause i think the ambition
was blind and man like you know we was
in another spectrum and spear man like
you know an atmosphere around that time
and trying to correlate you know
something like core audience
with commercial appeal you know and so
on and so forth and just trying to
try to pull it off and that's that's me
man like you didn't really like you know
i think it was some some different kind
of malfunctions and they're like
songs like amy and my very first white
girl and you know people
people like oh my god yeah it's funny
because
i felt that as a fan i was gonna say i
know that
that's why i'm being honest with you i'm
being transparent like because we've got
to keep it real that's a real
conversation
but you know what you guys have tried
this before in 2013. you know what i'm
saying that i
did what i'm saying so check it out so
it's like vinnie mom
always been controversial you know
and dangerous seems like you know like
the south's most dangerous group because
i like to you know look at it so
with that i felt like it it linked
itself to
you know a larger conversation but it
was supposed to be shock value
controversy blah blah blah blah blah
blah but instead of that
it just ended up just being a disconnect
to me like and disappointment
like you know because you know we might
even have to we might have to reach that
far
sometimes sometimes you want to reach to
to uh you know be like
to grab you know uh what you feel like
it's yours
in your reach but sometimes you stretch
yourself too bad
you know what i mean um and i will say
that i can be honest in saying that in
retrospect
but then there were some moments i think
people will also maybe listen back
to that project now especially
especially after we nailed it with this
project
i think people uh listen back to that
and be like okay
i can appreciate it more and see it in a
different light
for what they were trying to do in that
time period i'm saying you feel me but
like
the missing link of that album was the
cohesive
uh sonic uh you know sound bad
you know and just the energy you know
and the affection of organized noise
i was gonna say organized noise yeah
yeah yeah if you if you do something by
default
and everybody not not you know you can't
have you can't expect nobody to halfway
support you man like don't never ask
nobody to describe the offense
for you man like never no neutrals with
us man either parker drive
you know what i'm saying right i think
it's safe to say like
the people who are screaming they want a
goodie my album in 2020
are the people who want y'all to work
with organized boys they're the people
who like
they're like yo you know i think that
there's something to be said about i
just listened to i don't know if you
guys heard the new busta rhymes album
um yeah great album right but i i heard
his album and i was like yo
buster did not like busted
he took his time on the album but what
he did was he
made an album that he knew his core
diehard fans would appreciate in 2020
right right and i feel like
when i s when this and that album got
announced i was just so excited man
i was so excited because i if it would
have been announced without organized
mills
i would have checked it out but i was
like okay sonically this is going to be
something cohesive this is going to
bring back
you know this is and i and and and and
maybe the gift and the curse of the
pandemic you know we're getting a lot of
great music out of this panda
hey yo gil joe moe did i say anything
wrong about that
oh no that was
machine i mean you know what i'm saying
i mean a few songs just like you said
i mean we could have we could have did
something else but for me
it was two songs for me that i was like
damn i wish i hadn't got it on
and it was dirty south and black ice
right and we tried to do remixes for
them but they was not
the same right you feel what i'm saying
like
like we tried to do the remix with uh
with mystical
with uh uh was it dirty sound remix with
mystical yes
and then we did uh i forgot who produced
the
uh the black ice remix i think dj was
still the same wasn't it
yeah okay okay okay but yeah those are
the
two songs i like damn i wish i had a guy
with two songs right
you know black ice obviously is a record
that like you know it's like that [ __ ]
just needs to just be left alone you
know what i'm saying
oh we're uh breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man uh odd socks
oddssocksofficial.com
what the [ __ ] was that bro uh it was
like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair floating
in air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time's on the way
use the keyword boolean kev 20 off
oddssoxoficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go hey you guys also went through this
weird era of your career where the one
monkey don't stop the show album came
out
obviously that was the album that ceelo
was not part of
um how hard was it for you guys to get
through some of the
uh bumps in your guys's relationships
you know that
that that you know may or may not have
been public but how i i think
like you know at the end of the day you
guys we're here in 2020
you guys did an album after that but
like that specific just era
of your guys's relationship in the group
and at that point in time i think sealer
you were on your second solo album by
then
i think so yeah yeah yeah yeah machine
right
so what what was that era like because
at that time
hey man i'm a fan bro and look at the
the the single green
perfect imperfections that's my [ __ ]
disappoint when you drop that [ __ ] in o2
i was like this [ __ ] did not disappear
this is what i wanted from a silo album
it was trippy
um i mean like i said all of us
all of us grew up together you know what
i mean so
it wasn't nothing malicious to wear like
[ __ ] when i see that [ __ ]
it's on on site type [ __ ] so it ain't it
was it was never like that you know what
i mean so
it was just us being finding another way
to communicate you know what i'm saying
with our fans even though
you know what i'm saying we had we have
our little brother with us you know what
i mean but
it was much since i remember seeing
ceelo i didn't got them dead market one
day
you know what i'm saying we was in a
festival somewhere we were just
out there walking around man and i
forgot what year was that though
you remember when you're there
that was that was uh that's like
hold on that's that's old like oh six
yeah
something like that and when that one
monkey album come out when that come out
right offo oh folks so
we were still working and everything man
i just happened to see ceelo out and got
them a whole nother country man
in denmark man we was just like like
damn man what's up little brother like
man
see y'all man it was instant love man so
i still don't know what you had on boy
on a white dicky short set
was with a green shirt upon it
[Laughter]
that was my next question how much of
this [ __ ] did gip
star when it comes to the why because i
feel like he don't get enough praise
when it comes to
he don't introduce a lot of that wild
fashion [ __ ] into the game
what i'm gonna he don't speak for
himself but i don't want to speak on you
know just say this because
you know within our realm he would
definitely you know me like
doing it you know the the first like
even before i even really knew guilt
i knew of gear and gil had really kind
of made a name for himself for kind of
going against the grain so
everybody went gold get more silver you
know what i'm saying
and that's how i knew him like i i i had
uh been
introduced to or he had been spoken of
like i'm like you know you're gonna give
you a shield
so you can just tell that was
um you know that was like a calling card
that was a
trademark apparently it was noticeable
as [ __ ] in that time
and i mean but you know that you know
the big homies are a little older than
me so
i would only hear about certain stuff
but um so git was definitely making a
mark even in high school were just going
the other way with it
you know what i mean like he definitely
embellished on that within the group
you're saying like you know
and then an extension of that everybody
has some of this [ __ ] in them
so like you know especially when george
clinton
christened us the young part of me
funkadelic know me like
which basically gave us a license to ill
you know i'm saying like we can do
anything we want to just do
let me like and and the government says
it's okay
right we snap no say you feel me like
we're
and we could defend our right to be
different in the
drop of a dime you don't say you feel me
so it was no different than
africa bambara and the soul sonic force
being the black spades
before they christened themselves you
know
africa about zulu nation i mean like so
when they was wearing them costuming
back then it's like
imagine being in the middle of the burnt
down bronx with them [ __ ] goddamn
them roll you know what i'm saying like
that was probably the same kind of
effect that's what i like to get
and they got away with it and i knew
they was they was thorough because i
knew the backstory
so anybody from atlanta they knew what
our backstory was
and they knew we could defend it they
were that was [ __ ] man we just got to
catch up to these [ __ ] because they
also they on some
extraterrestrial art form type [ __ ] and
hey man
we ain't gonna say that we can't say
nothing about it don't say you feel me
like
because we won't it was interesting it
was intriguing
and people wanted to understand what the
expression was about
but it was just the rights of passage to
be you know um
just the individuals that we were gonna
be like we we fought for that do
something like and it was an easy win
too because like we brought
we had nuts man i'm saying like nuts
i knew for a fact i'm like man [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] somebody will tell us what
we can't do something like man we're
gonna laugh
we might even laugh when we get mad
don't say you feel me like
but i gotta tell you in 30 years man
like ain't nobody never disrespected us
bro i don't want a wedding dress man
like nobody listen you
you you wearing that silver or was it
gold you you were just a gold you you
you
when you went to that award show you was
right your whole head was golden
oh god that [ __ ] was crazy you went as
the award
so you know what i'm saying like it's
all fun it's all exhibitionism
pageantry you know what i'm saying like
it's definitely just being brave enough
to be yourself going against the odds
being different being
definitive being distinguishable you
know setting yourself apart
and then take it take heart and soul to
be yourself because
the main um identity crisis that
most people a society go through
is not wanting to be alone that's
painful
so you're looking for some people some
people they
they they sacrifice being an individual
for the sake of not having to be alone
for the sake of being accepted by the by
by people yeah no that's some real [ __ ]
that's real i mean
i i feel like another thing
in the beginning bro it's just i just
realized that
our dialect was different i realized
that
the way we perform was different and
i came up with i came up with in my own
head and i was like man if they
if they don't remember nothing we said
they're gonna remember what i look like
i just i remember we did we did a uh
a music conference in nashville and that
was the first time i did it
and i mixed this these short sets with
this
green alligator uh overall set
and i remember seeing it was us
and bad boy and i just remember seeing
how they looked at me like wow like look
like he looked wild
[Laughter]
but at the same time i knew that that
was something
that i had to continue to do so i just
started expounding on it i just came
back home and i just started going to
fabric stores and i just started
i just started testing things out i just
started going to magic city
and monkeying her pants and just
standing in there with all the girls and
the strippers and
the dope boys and just seeing how people
react to it and once i just started
doing that walking in there with
lime green all the way to the floor
jackets on
and the dope boy there being like oh
that jay gill
i was like i got him now i can do it i
can i can do it all the time
all right look real quick guys uh last
question i just want everybody
friday the 13th album comes out right
yeah
real quick uh let's say i put the album
in
right now i want everybody to give me a
different answer what's the first song i
should go listen to
i i know the right answer is i should
just press play and let that [ __ ] ride
which i'm gonna do but
give me give me everyone's favorite song
on the project
quick
back to back back to back for my people
what about you
curry goat what's it called
curry goat curry go all right well there
you go
listen friday the 13th fully produced by
organized noise the new goody mob album
is out go support that [ __ ] i appreciate
all all of y'all man for sitting down
with me and uh taking the time out of
your day man you guys are all legends i
appreciate y'all
y'all